you
when is Jerry I'm on choice calm I just
got paired up playing a five-o game so
let's see what we get here
okay let's try for a fee in keto and
will avoid any gambit play with a quick
capture on c4
double fiend keto hmm no let's take a
step with my epon and retain some
options with my deep on get a quick
castles in there all right so are they
really prepared to give up the light
square bishop seems like they are all
right
hmm each three takes Bishop takes pawn
takes pawn takes Queen d3 and now I
could chase the queen of whack and
return to return to e2
okay well where are the Knights homes
don't know I'm wondering where they are
because normally before you give up the
vicious pair
you would like to have a specific square
in mind to camp out with you one of your
nights
maybe that's a bit too strong of a
statement but what we can't say is right
now there aren't any great gaps for
these Knights to maybe take advantage my
position no holes in my position really
so where to go with my Queen Knights
let's go here
accuracy for a little bit more maybe I
play e4 and open it up or just once
let's hold hold my ground Queen c2 rook
d1 rook c1 let's put this rook here
first so if I need to sneak away with my
clean to be one I could do that really
quick
and let's start some a little bit of
expansion on the queenside a 3 B 4 they
could try to stop that with a 5
let's see any 5 is probably a good
choice ok so they're kind of floundering
without a plan if I play b4 maybe takes
and then the knight get camp out here
but you know what I'm still going to go
with this
they'd give up they'd have to give up
their Centrepointe and there's no
guarantee they could rely upon the d5
square anyway ooh now that move I did
not consider
well okay I don't think I could I don't
think it's a good idea to capture so at
least we're going to grab a little bit
of space on the queenside there won't be
any night to be six and I was thinking
on this move I blasted open here I'm
really trying to target the c6 pawn now
put to use this x-factor Bishop on light
square Bishop he should turn out to be
an animal
let's take with the night all right
many exchanges
for f5 and e4 be pretty committal nope
all right let's take here night soon to
be in a pin and the resulting structure
ties in well with my remaining bishop my
light-square bishop there also without
dark square bishop Spacek elise oh maybe
I could sneak into these squares one day
I don't know I think the most pressing
issue here for black is that the
positions opening up there's two
completely open files in the center and
one of their pieces will have to defend
c64 forever really as soon as he falls
then this guy's pretty quick
so evening out on the clock
there's an important moment you had to
relieve I had to respond just as I did
with the floral apply D 5 I had to hit
that with e 4
I'll just back up huh
bishop first now let's let's invite the
king out a little bit
yeah why not give a check that do
anything
[Music]
I want to go here I'm thinking about
maybe going to d69
probably keep that light square Bishop
huh
I go to f3 there's night here I wish I
had g3 and I could just call that all
the way back to g2
start with this check so that way here
night here I can maybe allow a knight
takes Bishop and get a have a major
piece specific ending and I could still
look to put pressure on the c6 pawn only
with my rook now so either way one of my
pieces basically wants to apply pressure
to c6 this is a nice spot on d6 for the
rook it's a hole I have support for it
okay let's back up
I guess my rooks will be challenged soon
Queens being challenged
okay well let's just
hop on in there
white square
there we go and so I will get a little
bit of something
hmm now I don't want to you know let's
just go here I split the structure but I
also would give a great spot for the
night on d5 with two pawns controlling
that so now the threat is to take and
then maybe go here
by winning upon now
I think I'm winning upon now now I take
and then play here and I'm hitting two
pawns one will fall
how to make this as clean as possible I
think I wanted to take with the bishop
box out tonight for one
and
just move and then take here or even
here
Bishop b7 even better yeah the bishop
will do a good job of supporting the
pawn on his way to promotion land c8
under 214 black
all right they're stopping that so let's
just come all the way back I'm hitting a
six now
and how about here threatening route b7
rip takes and then Bishop takes these
pawns will be hunted down
Knight to d7 you know I think I could
still just go they're connected past
prom it's pretty valuable
let's black going to come up with a
pretty passive it's not only me being up
upon but my pieces are both pieces that
I have are much better let's see what
comes up with so there
something better like
for this their nights passive 9 to d8 I
could slowly improve my king
Bishop for Knight exchange and it's a
one King and pawn endgame let's observe
a couple pawns
there's no way I'm letting that night
get active or did I speak too soon and I
speak a little too soon all right yeah
I'm allowing unnecessary counterplay
there okay we're going to take that
and not give that pun up so easily
past ponds it's an interesting try
otherwise it's a slow grind and actually
let's just improve the king still one
King and pawn endgame with these outside
pass pawns
I want to go here too quick yeah let's
let's start running with this guy now
I could push here and then here next I
have b7 covered so this is pushing
through now I wonder where wonder where
black went wrong just get it clean now I
play this out and now they resigned hmm
well b5 was certainly a bit of a shock
to me but I think I responded well I
should have at least anticipated that
move when a six was played it's just
kind of thinking a6 was a not quite sure
what I was thinking when a six played
when a six was played I don't think I
really
Shadid any idea connected with Asics
okay let me let me not go into the
analysis for just a moment anything to
note before I consult with stockfish
idea before I don't know if it's really
you know whites always going to have a
little bit something because of the
bishops and just slowly building up is a
fine approach I believe Knight d2 stays
out of the bishops way
just getting all my pieces playing and
then I'm ready for the opening up of the
position so yeah I create a gap here as
soon as I play this this is a hole and
my opponent try to take advantage of
that if I don't play this right away
Knight b6 and then I have to work around
the knight on c4 but I think how it was
a played out I'm able to still have
something because II five can be met
with e4 and then this is always an issue
as as was a well really demonstrated in
the game just keying in on the c6 square
I think I would hold off on playing b4
in this position maybe do something else
here in this middle game maybe eat maybe
e4 is the way to go open it up like that
yeah
think I'd maybe go with efore in this
position if I could do it over again
okay anyhow let's uh bring it up bring
up and open up the computer and see what
it has to say
alrighty stockfish let's see what you
have to say here kind of zip through the
opening stage it'll just be even ish but
let's see about this idea with like
giving up there light square bishop
it's probably point for us for me
something right around there
so they have their structure coordinated
with their bishop now and yeah just a
slight pull for me so really the one
position I want to have a look at is
once I have my Brooks in play rook a to
c1 and drug out to d1 probably both good
it's bouncing back and forth
as mentioned if things open up quickly
on the C file I'd like to quickly make
use of b1 and not get my Queen stuck in
between the rooks so in other words that
I played this and c5 I may want to go
here but I would want to have a
disconnect between my rooks
so therefore rook a to c1 first I get to
d1 next and you know clear clear waste
of time here for black with Bishop f8
and then going back to g7 not sure what
that was about
I mean if Bishop d6 then well yeah even
efore right now it's calling for you
know it's the way to go yeah it would be
pretty crazy to pull the bishop off of
this diagonal because there's no
guarantee whoops there's no guarantee
that
this pond will not have the opportunity
to push forward like after E for black
pretty much has to give up their strong
center points otherwise
I may just be a moment away from
acquiring a strategically one position
one where I grab space in both the
center and the queenside and black could
do nothing but sit in wait and the
Knights will have absolutely no activity
if I'm going to establish upon on e5 and
c5 not saying that that's best but it is
probably one approach to have a complete
clamp down and the black position of the
grabbing too much space
so basically e4 you have to take and now
this pawn is mobile and this Bishop can
see we could see id is connected with
the battery check mating ideas etc so
a bit of a waste of time in the end with
Bishop f8 and then returning to g7
Fisher to e2
I was saying I would maybe go with efore
let's have a look at e4 it's an idea
yeah I
let's just see a couple more moves
outtakes takes Bishop takes Queen e7
yeah
like remain solid but still have this
and from here I'd be looking for a
timely d5 break
um
to note in this position type is I
wouldn't be too quick to play d5 I don't
think I would try to get some prep moves
in such as maybe dropping the bishop
back staying out of a a knight move with
an attack against my Bishop and even go
for something like King G rg3 King to g2
and maybe even h4 if allowed maybe h5
and who knows maybe if I'm able to get
an h5 I bring the rook over to h1 so I
would go about it in a way where I'm
making small improvements before finally
breaking it open with d5 because I
believe black is in a position type
where they could really only do take up
a you know sit-in weight approach and
that's you know that ought that would
allow light to slowly build up the
position before finally breaking with d4
or okay
I went with v-form anyone would be five
and yeah see five and after let's go
with a five after E 5 doesn't want to
even go with E 4 z4 bad that's what I
did I think it could be bad now yeah
it's the right way forward
make sure that the center ponds are all
exchanged and in the end I really want
to get at c6
yeah I could already say that as soon as
b5 is played I want its e6 like right
now that's probably their weakest pun
right now as soon as b5 is played
whoops so you
d 6e 4 is the way any tactics missed
once things are opening up here Bishop
h6 popped up like that for a moment
takes and what more chop-chop-chop all
exchanges Bishop h6 yeah very uh you
know it's not so human to avoid the dark
square Bishop exchange and give me full
control of this it's a bit awkward for
sure
Queen e7 did I have some clear clear way
forward I took first
can't be a bad idea to have the King
exposed and on g7 to some checks that's
what I went for straight away
and what does it want to do let's Knight
to f6 so oh I could just jump in
did I play rip to d6 here now I just
backed up I could jump into d6 right now
okay in on this I'm taking here and then
I'd be on c6 twice with my rook and
queen okay so I don't have to back up I
lose a little something by doing that
rook d6 is better
you know for the Queen exchange and
still right around upon advantage
that's it's just tough now I want this
this is fine as mentioned in the game I
didn't want to give this square up yeah
that was that wouldn't have been good
would have been far more difficult for
me to show that this is a weakness if
there's a a pawn on e6 he's isolated but
he has a very important role of
supporting a Knight d5 move
so that's why I just doubled and now
it's just winning in exchange and then
jump into d6 anything missed right
around here plus two and growing
think so
yeah that night got a little bit active
but by now it's just too much to pass
pawns and I'm not two pawns
and yeah just improve the king and I'm
pushing through now bad idea okay
well interesting game feel free as usual
to leave any feedback to this video in
the comment section below hope you're
having a great day and I will catch you
soon that is all for now take care bye